En 1962, Charles Van Doren —más tarde editor jefe de la Enciclopedia Británica—
dijo que la enciclopedia ideal debería ser radical —debería dejar de ser prudente.
Pero si saben algo de la historia de la Británica desde 1962,
fue todo menos radical.
Era un tipo de enciclopedia poco arriesgada y muy pesada.
Por el contrario, Wikipedia parte de una idea muy radical,
que todos imaginemos un mundo
en el que todas las personas del planeta
dispongan de acceso gratis a todo el conocimiento humano.
Y eso es lo que hacemos. Así que Wikipedia,
— acaban de ver una pequeña demostración de esto—
es una enciclopedia de licencia libre. La escriben miles de voluntarios
de todo el mundo en muchas lenguas.
Se escribe usando software Wiki,
que es un tipo de software que se acaba de mostrar
—de modo que todos puedan editar y guardar,
y aparece de inmediato en internet.
Y casi todo lo relativo a Wikipedia se organiza mediante una plantilla de voluntarios.
Así que cuando Yochai habla de nuevos métodos de organización,
describe justamente Wikipedia. Y lo que haré hoy
es hablarles de cómo funciona realmente por dentro.
Wikipedia es propiedad de la Fundación Wikimedia que yo fundé,
una organización sin ánimo de lucro. Y el objetivo fundamental de la Fundación Wikimedia,
es dar acceso gratuito a una enciclopedia a cada una de las personas del planeta.
Así que si piensan en lo que eso significa,
implica mucho más que simplemente crear una página web chula.
Estamos realmente interesados en la brecha social digital, en la pobreza del mundo,
en empoderar a la gente en todas partes para que tengan la información
que les permita tomar buenas decisiones.
Así que tendremos mucho trabajo que va más allá de Internet.
Y eso explica en gran medida por qué hemos elegido un modelo de licencia libre,
porque eso empodera a los empresarios locales,
o a quien quiera, para que usen nuestros contenidos
y hagan lo que quieran —se puede copiar, redistribuir,
y se puede usar con o sin fines comerciales.
Así que surgirán muchas oportunidades en torno a Wikipedia
en todo el mundo.
Nuestros fondos provienen de donaciones particulares,
y una de las cosas más interesantes sobre eso
es lo poco que cuesta dirigir Wikipedia.
Yochai les mostró el gráfico de lo que costaba una imprenta.
Y yo les diré cuánto cuesta Wikipedia,
pero antes les mostraré cuán grande es.
Tenemos más de 600 000 artículos en inglés.
Y un total de dos millones de artículos en muchas lenguas diferentes.
Las lenguas con más fuerza son el alemán, el japonés, el francés.
Todas las lenguas del oeste de Europa tienen bastante fuerza.
Pero solo alrededor de un tercio de todo el tráfico a nuestro sitio
desemboca en Wikipedia en inglés,
lo cual sorprende a mucha gente.
Muchas personas piensan en Internet de modo muy anglo-céntrico,
pero somos realmente globales. Existimos en muchas lenguas.
Lo populares que nos hemos hecho —somos uno de los 50 sitios web más visitados
y somos más populares que el New York Times.
Aquí es donde llegamos a la discusión de Yochai.
Esto nos muestra el crecimiento de Wikipedia —somos la línea azul de ahí
y este de ahí es el New York Times—.
Y lo interesante de esto es que el sitio del New York Times
es una operación corporativa enorme con —no tengo ni idea de cuántos—, cientos de empleados.
Nosotros tenemos exactamente un empleado,
y ese empleado es nuestro principal programador de software.
Y es nuestro empleado desde solo enero de 2005,
todo nuestro otro crecimiento vino antes de eso.
Así que los servidores se organizan mediante un grupo de voluntarios,
así como todo el trabajo editorial.
Y la manera de organizarnos
no es como la de cualquier otra organización que imaginen.
La gente siempre pregunta, "¿Quién dirige todo esto?"
o "¿Quién hace eso?" Y la respuesta es: quienquiera que quiera involucrarse.
Es algo poco usual y caótico.
Ahora tenemos más de 90 servidores en tres lugares.
Un sistema de administradores voluntarios en línea los controlan.
Puedo contectarme a Internet en cualquier momento del día o noche
y ver de 8 a 10 personas esperando
a que les pregunte cualquier cosa acerca de los servidores.
Nunca uno se podría permitir eso en una compañía.
Nunca sería asequible tener un grupo de gente de guardia
24 horas al día, haciendo lo que hacemos en Wikipedia.
Tenemos 1.4 billones de visitas al mes,
así que se ha convertido en algo enorme.
Y todo lo organizan voluntarios.
El coste mensual total de la banda ancha es de unos USD 5 000 .
Y ese es nuestro gasto principal.
De hecho podríamos prescindir de ese empleado. En realidad,
contratamos a Brian porque llevaba trabajando dos años a tiempo parcial
y a tiempo completo en Wikipedia,
así que al final lo contratamos para que pudiera tener vida propia e ir al cine de vez en cuando.
Así que la gran pregunta cuando uno se enfrenta a una organización realmente caótica como esta, es:
¿cómo es que no es todo una porquería? ¿por qué es tan bueno el sitio?
Primero, ¿cuán bueno es? Bastante. No es perfecto,
pero es mucho mejor de lo que uno esperaría,
teniendo en cuenta un modelo tan caótico como el nuestro.
Así que cuando vieron como él editaba ridículamente mi página
quizá piensen: "Esto degenerará en basura."
Pero al ver pruebas de calidad — y de éstas no ha habido suficientes todavía,
por eso animo sinceramente a la gente a que lo haga más— ,
comparando Wikipedia con productos tradicionales —ganamos de calle.
Una revista alemana comparó la Wikipedia alemana,
que es mucho más pequeña que la inglesa,
con Microsoft Encarta y Brockhaus Multimedia,
y ganamos en todo.
Contrataron a expertos para que compararan la calidad de los artículos,
y el resultado nos satisfizo mucho.
Mucha gente sabe de la controversia Bush-Kerry en Wikipedia.
Esto es, —los medios de comunicación han cubierto esto ampliamente.—
Empezó con un artículo en Red Herring.
Los reporteros me llamaron
deletrearon bien mi nombre, ero lo que de verdad querían decir era:
las elecciones Bush-Kerry son tan polémicas,
que están dividiendo a la comunidad de Wikipedia. Y me citaron diciendo:
"Son las más polémicas de la historia de Wikipedia."
Lo que dije en realidad es que no son polémicas, en absoluto.
Es una cita ligeramente errónea. Los artículos se editaron bastante.
Y es cierto que tuvimos que bloquear los artículos un par de veces.
La revista Time informó recientemente de que
"A veces hay que tomar medidas extremas,
y Wales bloqueó las entradas sobre Kerry y Bush durante la mayor parte de 2004."
Esto se dijo después de que le dijera al periodista que teníamos que bloquearlo—
ocasionalmente, un poco aquí y allá.
Así que, la verdad, en general es que este tipo de polémicas
que Uds. probablemente pensarían que tenemos en la comunidad de Wikipedia
no son polémicas en absoluto.
Los artículos sobre temas controvertidos se editan mucho,
pero no causan mucha polémica dentro de la comunidad.
Y la razón es que la mayoría entiende la necesidad de ser neutrales.
La lucha de verdad no es entre la derecha y la izquierda,
eso es lo que la mayoría asume,
sino entre el partido de los que piensan y el de los imbéciles.
Y ninguna tendencia del espectro político tiene el monopolio de esas cualidades.
La auténtica verdad sobre el incidente Bush-Kerry
es que los artículos sobre Bush-Kerry
fueron bloqueados menos del 1% del tiempo en 2004,
y no fue porque fueran polémicos;
fue porque estaban sujetos a vandalismo,
lo cual sucede a veces incluso en el escenario,
a veces incluso los periodistas me han informado de que vandalizan Wikipedia
y se sorprenden de lo rápido que se corrige.
Y les dije, siempre digo, por favor, no hagan eso, no es bueno.
Así que, ¿cómo lo hacemos?
¿Cómo regulamos el control de calidad?
¿Cómo se hace? ¿cómo funciona?
Aquí tienen algunos elementos,
sobre todo normas sociales y algunos elementos del software.
Lo más importante es nuestra política de neutralidad.
Esto es algo que desde el principio constituí
en un principio central de la comunidad que no está sujeto a debate.
Es un concepto social de cooperación,
así que no hablamos mucho de la verdad y la objetividad.
La razón es que si decimos que solo escribiremos la verdad sobre un tema,
eso no nos ayuda a la hora de decidir qué escribir,
porque no estoy de acuerdo contigo en qué es la verdad.
Pero tenemos este término de neutralidad,
con una larga historia en la comunidad,
que básicamente explica que cuando haya un tema controvertido
Wikipedia no debería tomar partido.
Debemos informar meramente de lo que fuentes acreditadas han dicho sobre ello.
Esta política de neutralidad es realmente importante para nosotros,
porque empodera a una comunidad que es muy diversa
para que se una y consiga cosas de verdad.
Así que tenemos colaboradores con trasfondos políticos, religiosos
y culturales muy diversos.
Al tener una política de neutralidad firme,
que desde el principio no es negociable,
nos aseguramos de que la gente puede trabajar junta
y de que las entradas no se conviertan en una guerra constante
entre izquierda y derecha.
Si alguien muestra ese comportamiento,
se le pedirá que abandone la comunidad.
Así que hay revisiones hechas por colegas en tiempo real.
Todos y cada uno de los cambios en el sitio van a la página de cambios recientes.
Así que en cuanto él hizo el cambio, fui a la página de cambios recientes.
Esa página de cambios recientes también llega a un canal de IRC,
que es un canal de chat en Internet
que la gente vigila con varias herramientas de software.
Y la gente puede acceder a feeds RSS —
y pueden recibir correos con los cambios.
Y luego los usuarios pueden crear una lista de vigilancia propia.
Mi página está en las listas de bastantes voluntarios,
porque a veces es objeto de vandalismo.
Y lo que pasa es que alguien se dará cuenta del cambio rápidamente,
y simplemente lo eliminará.
Por ejemplo, hay un nuevo feed de páginas
que permite acceder a cierta página de Wikipedia
y ver todas las páginas nuevas a media que se crean.
Esto es muy importante, porque muchas páginas nuevas
son porquería y tienen que borrarse.
Pero esas son algunas de las cosas más interesantes y divertidas en Wikipedia,
algunos de esos artículos nuevos.
La gente empieza un artículo sobre un tema interesante,
otras personas lo encontrarán fascinante
y se unirán para ayudar y mejorarlo.
Tenemos a usuarios anónimos que editan,
esto es una de las cosas más controvertidas y fascinantes sobre Wikipedia.
Así que Chris pudo hacer su cambio, no tuvo que registrarse ni nada,
simplemente estaba en la página e hizo un cambio.
Pero resulta que solo alrededor del 18 % de todas las correcciones
las hacen usuarios anónimos.
Y esto es algo importante de comprender
la inmensa mayoría de las correcciones que aparecen en el sitio
provienen de una comunidad muy unida de entre 600 y 1 000 personas
que se comunican constantemente.
Y tenemos más de 40 canales IRC, 40 listas de correo.
Y todas estas personas se conocen. Se comunican, tienen reuniones offline.
Esas son las personas que crean la mayor parte del sitio
y, en cierto modo, son semiprofesionales de lo que hacen,
en el sentido de que el control de calidad que nos exigimos es igual o mayor
que el de los profesionales.
No siempre llegamos a ese nivel,
pero es lo que intentamos.
Así que esa comunidad tan unida es la que de verdad se preocupa del sitio,
y son algunas de las personas más brillantes que conozco.
Desde luego, es mi trabajo decir eso, pero es la verdad.
El tipo de gente a la que le atrae escribir una enciclopedia para divertirse
tiende a ser bastante inteligente.
Las herramientas y el software: hay muchas herramientas que nos permiten
a la comunidad autocontrolarnos y vigilar todo el trabajo.
Este es un ejemplo del historial de una página sobre la "tierra plana",
y pueden ver algunos de los cambios hechos.
Lo que me gusta de esta página es que, de inmediato, se puede consultar esto
y darse cuenta, "vale, ahora lo entiendo".
Cuando alguien lo consulta, se ve que alguien,
un número IP anónimo, editó mi página.
Sospechoso ¿quién es esta persona? Alguien se fija,
y puede ver inmediatamente resaltados en rojo todos los cambios hechos,
y ver, bueno, vale, estas palabras han cambiado, cosas como esta.
Es una herramienta que se puede usar muy rápido para controlar el historial de una página.
Otra cosa que hacemos en la comunidad
es dejar todo abierto.
La mayoría de las normas sociales y métodos de trabajo
se dejan completamente abiertos en el software.
Todo eso está en páginas Wiki.
Así que no hay nada en el software que haga valer las normas.
El ejemplo que muestro aquí es una página de consulta de borrado.
Como dije antes, la gente escribe tonterías,
hay que borrarlo. En casos como ese, los administradores simplemente lo borran.
No hay por qué tener una discusión sobre eso.
Pero pueden imaginar que hay muchas otras áreas en las que la pregunta es,
¿es esto suficientemente importante para aparecer en una enciclopedia?
¿Es la información verificable? ¿Es un engaño? ¿Es verdad? ¿Qué es?
Necesitamos un método social para encontrar la solución.
Y el método que surgió de modo natural dentro de la comunidad:
es la página de consulta de borrado.
Y en el ejemplo particular que tenemos aquí, es una película,
"Twisted Issues", y la primera persona dice,
"Se supone que esto es una película. Falla el test de google estrepitosamente."
El test de Google es: miras en Google y ves si está ahí,
porque si algo ni siquiera está en Google, probablemente no existe en absoluto.
No es una regla perfecta, pero es un buen punto de partida para investigar con rapidez.
Así que alguien dice, "Bórrenlo, por favor. Bórrenlo, no es importante."
Y entonces alguien dice, "Esperen, esperen, esperen. Lo encontré."
Lo encontré en un libro, "Guía de vídeo de la Revista Film Threat:
Las 20 películas underground que hay que ver."
Oh, vale. Así que la siguiente persona dice: "Limpiémoslo."
Alguien dice, "Lo he encontrado en IMDB. Sigamos, sigamos."
Lo interesante de esto es que el software es...
los votos son simplemente texto escrito en una página.
No es tanto un voto como un diálogo.
Es cierto que al final
un administrador puede revisarlo y decir,
18 votos a favor de borrar, 2 a favor de seguir, lo borramos.
Pero en otros casos, puede haber 18 a favor de borrar y 2 de seguir, y lo mantendríamos,
porque si esos dos dicen, "Esperemos un poco, esperemos.
nadie ha visto esto pero yo lo encontré en un libro,
y encontré un enlace a una página que lo describe, y lo arreglaré mañana,
por favor no lo borren," entonces sobreviviría.
Y también importa quienes son las personas que votan.
Como digo, es una comunidad estrecha.
Aquí abajo, "Mantener, película real," Rick Kay.
Rick Kay es un wikipedista famoso
que trabaja mucho contra el vandalismo, los artículos falsos
y los votos para borrar.
Su voz tiene mucho peso en la comunidad
porque sabe lo que hace.
Así que ¿cómo se gobierna todo esto?
La gente realmente quiere saber cosas sobre los administradores, cosas de esas.
Así que el modelo de gobierno de Wikipedia, el gobierno de la comunidad,
es una mezcla de consenso muy confusa pero que permite trabajar,
es decir, que intentamos no votar el contenido de los artículos,
porque la opinión de la mayoría no necesariamente es neutral.
Cierto nivel de democracia. Todos los administradores,
esos tienen la capacidad de borrar páginas.
Eso no quiere decir que tengan el derecho a borrar páginas,
ellos también tienen que seguir normas, pero a ellos se les elige.
Son elegidos por la comunidad. A veces a la gente
con bulos que surgen en Internet, le gusta acusarme de nombrar a dedo a los administradores
para sesgar el contenido de la enciclopedia.
Siempre me río de esto, porque no tengo ni idea de cómo se los elige.
Hay un cierto nivel de aristocracia.
Y puede que tuvieran un amago de eso cuando mencioné
que la voz de Rick Kay tiene mucho más peso que la de alguien a quien no conocemos.
A veces doy esta charla con Angela, que acaba de ser reelegida
para la Junta de la comunidad, para la Junta de la Fundación,
con más del doble de los votos que la persona no seleccionada.
Y siempre la avergüenzo porque digo que, por ejemplo, Angela
podría salirse con la suya haciendo lo que le diera la real gana en Wikipedia
porque se la admira mucho y es poderosa.
Pero la ironía es, desde luego, que Angela puede hacer eso porque es la única persona
que nunca jamás, rompe ninguna regla de Wikipedia.
Y también me gustaría decir que es la única persona
que conoce todas las reglas de Wikipedia...
y también está la monarquía, y ese es mi papel en la comunidad...
Lo expliqué una vez en Berlín y al día siguiente el titular
de un periódico decía: "Soy la Reina de Inglaterra."
Y eso no es exactamente lo que dije, pero,
lo que quiero aclarar es mi papel en la comunidad
dentro del mundo del software.
Ha habido una vieja y duradera tradición del modelo del dictador benevolente.
Así que al observar la mayoría de los principales proyectos de software libre,
tienen una sola persona a cargo
y todos están de acuerdo en que es el dictador benevolente.
No me gusta el término dictador benevolente,
y no creo que sea mi trabajo o mi papel en el mundo de las ideas
ser el dictador del futuro de todo el conocimiento humano compilado por el mundo.
Simplemente no es apropiado.
Aún así, hace falta un cierto nivel de monarquía,
una cierta cantidad de... A veces hay que tomar una decisión,
y no queremos atascarnos demasiado
en tomas de decisión formales.
Como ejemplo de por qué ha sucedido esto
o de qué manera puede ser relevante,
recientemente tuvimos una situación donde un sitio neo-nazi descubrió Wikipedia,
y dijeron, "Oh, esto es horrible, este sitio es una conspiración judía
y haremos que se borren ciertos artículos que no nos gustan.
Y como tienen un proceso de votación, enviaremos votos.
Tenemos 40.000 miembros y vamos a hacer
que voten para conseguir que se borren estas páginas."
Solo consiguieron que aparecieran 18 personas.
Eso son matemáticas neo-nazis.
Siempre piensan que son 40 000 miembros cuando son 18.
Pero consiguieron que 18 personas votaran de manera bastante absurda
para borrar un artículo perfectamente válido.
Desde luego, la votación terminó siendo más o menos de 85 a 18,
así que no había un peligro real para nuestro proceso democrático.
Por otra parte, la gente dice: "Pero, ¿qué vamos a hacer?
Esto podría pasar y ¿si un grupo se organiza de verdad
y entra y quiere votar?"
Y entonces dije, "A la mierda, cambiaremos la normas."
Ese es mi trabajo en la comunidad: decir que no permitiremos que nuestro carácter abierto
y nuestra libertad resten calidad al contenido.
Así que mientras la gente confíe en mi papel,
hay un lugar válido para mí.
Evidentemente, por la licencia libre, si hago mal mi trabajo,
los voluntarios son libres de irse.
No puedo decirle a nadie qué hacer.
El último punto es que para entender cómo funciona Wikipedia
es importante entender que nuestro modelo Wiki es nuestra forma de trabajar,
pero no somos anarquistas fanáticos de la red. De hecho,
somos muy flexibles en cuanto a la metodología social,
porque la pasión de la comunidad estriba en la calidad del trabajo,
no necesariamente por el proceso usado para generarlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Ben Saunders: Sí, hola, Ben Saunders.
Jimmy, mencionaste que la imparcialidad es un elemento clave del éxito de Wikipedia.
Me choca que muchos de los libros de texto
que se usan para educar a nuestros niños estén inherentemente sesgados.
¿Has encontrado a profesores que usan Wikipedia,
y cómo crees que Wikipedia puede cambiar la educación?
Jimmy Wales: Si, muchos profesores están empezando a usar Wikipedoa.
Hay otra historia mediática sobre Wikipedia que creo que es falsa.
Se basa en la historia de los blogueros contra los periódicos.
Y la historia es, existe esta locura, Wikipedia,
pero los académicos la odian y los profesores la odian. Y resulta que no es cierto.
La última vez que recibí un correo de un periodista preguntaba:
"¿Por que odian los académicos Wikipedia?"
Lo envié desde mi dirección de correo de Harvard,
porque acaban de nombrarme miembro de la universidad.
Y dije, "Bueno, no todos la odian."
Pero creo que habrá un gran impacto.
Y de hecho tenemos un proyecto
que personalmente me emociona,
que es el proyecto de libros Wiki,
un esfuerzo por crear libros de texto en todas las lenguas.
Ese es un proyecto mucho mayor;
tardará unos 20 años en dar frutos.
Pero parte de eso es para cumplir nuestra misión
de dar una enciclopedia a todas y cada una de las personas del planeta.
Y no me refiero a que les vayamos a bombardear con CDs
Queremos decir que les daremos una herramienta que puedan usar.
Y para mucha gente en el mundo,
si le doy una enciclopedia escrita a nivel universitario,
no le hace ningún bien
sin muchos materiales complementarios
para formarle hasta llegar al punto en que pueda usarla de verdad.
Los libros Wiki son un intento de hacer eso.
Y creo que vamos a ver un inmenso...
puede que no surja de nosotros,
hay mucha innovación en progreso.
Pero los libros de texto de licencia libre serán la próxima revolución en educación.